we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p i
don't know where people are getting
these ideas but here is someone alleging
that the david pakman show and the kyle
kolinsky show are receiving DNC funding
which is as untrue as it is laughable
and I'll tell you why in a second hi
David my name is Michael and I was just
curious because I heard from some
progressive outlets that yourself and
individuals like Kyle kolinsky have been
taking large funds from the DNC I'm
curious to know whether or not this is
true and if so why do you do it
mm-hmm another thing I wanted to know is
what are you on a libertarian
Progressive Alliance okay I don't care
about libertarian Progressive Alliance
no we're not getting any DNC money you
know III don't know if the DNC supports
media outlets that are not like the big
corporate corporate legacy ones but if
they did I don't think they would
support the progressive ones where the
hosts have said they're voting for
Bernie Sanders something tells me that
that's not that's not the wheelhouse of
the DNC to start throwing throwing cash
around on the bonus show today we will
talk about Elizabeth Warren's reaction
to Michael Bloomberg's NDA pledge on
those non-disclosure agreements we will
talk about a daredevil flat earther who
has died after attempting to launch
himself with a homemade rocket and we
will also talk about the Supreme Court
taking up a religious liberty dispute on
the issues of same-sex marriage and
foster care all of that and more on
today's bonus show